(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre o checklist
dos leilões excrujudiciais, o passo a passo que
você vai seguir antes de arrematar qualquer imóvel
em leilão excrujudicial.
O arquivo do checklist está disponível aqui na
aula para download.
Sempre verifique todos os itens antes de participar
de algum leilão.
O checklist nada mais é do que um
compilado de todas as informações que a gente
falou no módulo 2, mas que vai facilitar
a sua vida.
Então, primeira coisa que você vai analisar sempre,
verificar a viabilidade financeira do leilão de acordo
com a sua finalidade.
Investimento ou moradia.
É muito importante que você faça a sua
viabilidade financeira contando com todos os gastos que
você vai ter com aquele imóvel e que
você sempre confira o real valor de mercado
daquele imóvel.
Nunca confie no que está lá no site
do leiloeiro.
Então, use os grandes portais de venda como
Zap, Viva Real ou LX.
Em algumas cidades, Quintandar, Loft, contato com corretores
daquela região, contato com síndico, porteiro e zelador
para saber qual foi o valor de venda
do último imóvel lá naquele condomínio.
Faça esse apanhado geral para saber se, de
fato, aquele imóvel vale quanto está sendo indicado
lá no site do leiloeiro.
Nunca confie nesse valor.
Procure, então, imóveis similares com mesma metragem, mesma
localização, mesmas características, áreas de lazer, para que
você tenha plena noção quanto a isso.
Segundo ponto, edital do leilão.
É tudo o que você vai verificar no
edital do leilão, como data e horário, valor
de primeiro e segundo leilão, se as dívidas
anteriores ao leilão de condomínio e IPTU serão
quitadas pelo credor ou serão de responsabilidade do
arrematante, a gente já sabe que existem editais
aí das duas formas, quitando tudo ou passando
para o arrematante as dívidas de condomínio e
IPTU.
Conferir se tem gravames para analisar alguma penhora
lá que recaia sobre aquele imóvel.
Se você não lembra qual é a consequência
de ter alguma penhora no imóvel que tem
na leilão excluidicial, relembre na aula específica aqui
do módulo 2.
Conferir se há alguma ação judicial do devedor
contra o credor fiduciário, porque se existir lá
a informação de que tem alguma ação judicial,
pode ser que a evicção de direitos tenha
sido limitada.
Conferir se o edital está levando ao leilão
o imóvel e as vagas de garagem, caso
a matrícula seja individualizada.
Isso é aquele caso que a gente já
falou lá de apartamento que tem matrículas diferentes
para o apartamento e para as vagas de
garagem.
Então, se todas as matrículas não estiverem no
edital do leilão, você pode arrematar só o
apartamento sem as vagas.
Isso é um prejuízo, porque não vai valer
a mesma coisa que um apartamento com as
vagas.
Então, fique sempre bem atento.
A gente falou sobre isso no módulo 1.
Qualquer coisa, volte lá na aula.
7.
De quem será a responsabilidade por dar baixa
em algum ônus ou gravame?
Isso aí retoma ao ponto 4.
E aquela importância de ver lá se tem
alguma penhora recaindo no imóvel.
De quem vai ser a responsabilidade por cancelar
aquela penhora?
Do vendedor ou do arrematante?
3.
Matrícula do imóvel.
Confira a metragem para saber certinho toda a
descrição daquele imóvel.
Verificar se a vaga de garagem está na
mesma matrícula ou se está matrícula independente.
Isso aí para imóveis em condomínio, sempre fique
muito atento.
Analisar possíveis ônus e gravames que possam existir.
E conferir se há a verbação da consolidação
da propriedade em nome do credor fiduciário.
Muito importante, quando existe a alienação fiduciária registrada
na matrícula, depois vai ter que existir a
consolidação da propriedade para que o imóvel seja
levado ao leilão.
4.
Procedimento do leilão.
Em primeiro lugar, analisar se foi feito o
registro da alienação fiduciária na matrícula do imóvel
e da consolidação da propriedade em nome do
credor.
Acabei de falar que é algo muito importante,
exceto se for dação em pagamento.
A gente já sabe que em dação em
pagamento é aquela troca, né?
O credor aceita ficar com o imóvel em
troca da dívida.
Então, não vai existir a consolidação da propriedade
ali naquele imóvel.
Vai existir alienação fiduciária e dação em pagamento,
porque a dação em pagamento significa transferência definitiva
do imóvel que deixa de ser do devedor
e passa a ser do credor.
O credor, quando tem dação em pagamento, ele
vende o imóvel da forma que ele quiser,
porque ele está livre, não tem nada ali
da lei em cima dele, falando de primeiro
leilão, segundo leilão e os valores mínimos.
Ele é de fato proprietário, ele trocou ali
em um acordo com o devedor a dívida
pelo imóvel sem precisar cumprir os requisitos da
lei, primeiro e segundo leilão e consolidação da
propriedade.
Então, ele vende da forma e pelo valor
que ele quiser.
Como a gente está falando aí, na maioria
dos casos dos bancos, e os bancos são
acostumados a fazer leilão, os bancos acabam optando
por colocar esse imóvel aí também em leilão,
de dação em pagamento, mas aí com os
critérios que ele estabelecer, não se aplica lá
a lei 9.514 D-97.
Analisar se a informação na matrícula de que
os devedores foram notificados para purgar a mora,
geralmente no mesmo registro, lá da consolidação da
propriedade, consta essa informação, a gente vai ver
na prática, isso aí nas análises que a
gente vai fazer dos imóveis a seguir.
Analisar se a descrição do imóvel digital é
igual da matrícula.
Toda matrícula, ela começa ali com os dados
daquele imóvel.
Todos aqueles dados têm que ser reproduzidos no
edital do leilão.
Então, sempre confira se está tudo batendo ali,
se por acaso alguma coisa não bater, existe
a chance de aquele leilão ter um vício,
até ser anulado por um vício ali na
falha da descrição dos dados daquele imóvel.
4.
Verificar com o leiloeiro se os devedores foram
notificados das datas do leilão, diferente da notificação
para purgar a mora que consta na matrícula,
essa notificação das datas do leilão não consta
na matrícula, a forma de você saber é
realmente ligando para o leiloeiro.
Essa notificação das datas do leilão é muito
simples, ela pode ser feita por telegrama ou
até mesmo por e-mail para os devedores.
Então, não tem motivo nenhum para que essa
notificação não seja respeitada, é diferente da notificação
para purgar a mora.
A notificação para purgar a mora tem um
procedimento complexo, tem que ser feita por cartório,
tem que respeitá-la todo aquele trâmite da
lei.
Então, ela é uma notificação bem mais complexa.
A notificação das datas do leilão é muito
simples, pode ser por telegrama ou por e
-mail até.
Sempre ligue para o leiloeiro porque isso aí
não consta na matrícula do imóvel.
E aí, quando você ligar para o leiloeiro,
o leiloeiro vai falar que essa obrigação é
do credor.
Pode ser que o leiloeiro te fale isso.
E, de fato, essa obrigação é do credor,
quem tem que notificar é o credor, não
é o leiloeiro.
Se, por acaso, o leiloeiro te informar que
ele não tem essa notificação porque essa notificação
é uma obrigação do credor, peça o contato
do credor para você falar diretamente com ele.
Como a maioria dos credores são bancos, em
algumas vezes que a gente entra em contato
com o número que o leiloeiro passou, pode
ser que o banco fale que ele não
pode passar aquela informação, que ele só poderia
apresentar em juízo, já que aquela informação faz
parte do sigilo que envolve os dados do
banco.
Então, se você não conseguir, analise todo o
checklist, se tiver tudo ok, siga com esse
leilão normalmente, porque essa notificação é muito, muito,
muito simples, não tem motivo nenhum para o
credor deixar de fazer essa notificação.
Passou por todo o checklist, está tudo certo?
Beleza, bola para frente, pode participar desse leilão.
Analisar de quem será a responsabilidade por débitos
de IPTU e condomínio, anteriores ao leilão, que
a gente já sabe que cada caso é
um caso.
Verificar se o imóvel está ocupado ou desocupado
no edital e na prática.
O edital, via de regra, ele sempre informa
se o imóvel está ocupado ou desocupado, mas
sempre verifique na prática, porque pode ser que
o edital fale que o imóvel está ocupado,
você vê na prática que está desocupado, a
pessoa já até saiu sabendo que o imóvel
é leilão, ali você já tem uma garantia
absoluta de que você não precisa tentar acordo,
de que você não precisa dar ação de
emissão na próxima, sua vida vai ser muito
mais fácil.
E também, a função de verificar isso aqui
é saber quem está ocupando aquele imóvel, já
que a gente só deve participar dos leilões
em que o próprio devedor está ocupando o
imóvel ou o inquilino com o contrato com
esse devedor.
Devemos sempre ficar de fora de imóvel que
tem ali um invasor ou imóvel que tem
um contrato de gaveta, que é aquele contrato
que só tem validade em três partes, ele
não é uma venda plenamente eficaz, não é
registrada na matrícula, mas mesmo assim pode dar
em sejo a uma ação de uso campeão.
Então verifique, é o devedor com a sua
família?
Beleza.
É o locatário com o contrato de locação
com o devedor?
Beleza, pode participar.
Não é?
Ninguém sabe, ninguém conhece esse devedor, ninguém sabe
quem é ou falaram que esse devedor vendeu
o imóvel para alguém há muito tempo?
Fica de fora, passa para frente, não vale
a pena você participar desse leilão.
Quinto passo, verificar a existência de processos judiciais
entre devedor e credor.
Você sempre vai verificar isso, porque a gente
sabe que se constar na matrícula e na
página de divulgação do leiloeiro, o credor pode
limitar a evicção de direitos.
Mas por que você sempre vai analisar, mesmo
que não conste na matrícula e no material
de divulgação?
Porque você vai saber qual é o perfil
daquele devedor, saber se aquele devedor está brigando
com alguma coisa, está tentando anular o leilão,
está tentando alegar algum vício ou não, se
ele está deixando o barco tocar.
E se existir processo de devedor contra o
credor, você vai saber o que o judiciário
está falando.
Se mandou seguir com o leilão?
Se vai mandar suspender aquele leilão até uma
decisão definitiva?
Se falou já que o devedor não tem
nenhum direito, que não tem nenhuma razão naquela
alegação que ele fez, então sempre pesquise.
A regra é que os processos judiciais são
públicos, então você vai conseguir, se localizar um
processo, se existir, você vai conseguir ler essa
decisão.
Vou mostrar aqui na prática como funciona essa
busca pelos processos.
A gente tem ali os credores, que na
maioria das vezes são bancos, ou tanto faz
se for alguma outra instituição que tenha feito
esse contrato e a gente vai dividir em
dois grupos.
Um grupo é só a Caixa Econômica Federal
e o outro grupo são todos os demais
credores que possam existir.
Todos os demais credores, se o devedor quiser
alegar alguma coisa contra aquele credor, ele vai
ter que entrar com processo na Justiça Estadual,
que é a Justiça Comum, Tribunal de Justiça
do Estado, onde fica localizado aquele imóvel.
Se for a Caixa Econômica, a Caixa Econômica
tem que ser processada na Justiça Federal.
Então você vai procurar algum processo do devedor
contra o credor na Justiça Federal e não
na Justiça Estadual.
Então todos os credores, Justiça Comum, Tribunal de
Justiça do Estado, onde o imóvel fica localizado.
Caixa Econômica, Justiça Federal, daquele Estado onde o
imóvel fica localizado.
Com a ajuda do Google, você vai pesquisar,
por exemplo, TJ de São Paulo.
O próprio Google vai te retornar aqui, já
tem o campo da consulta processual.
Você vai abrir, primeiro grau, todo o processo
do devedor contra o credor começa em primeiro
grau.
E você vai mudar, vai colocar o nome
da parte, coloque sempre o nome do devedor,
porque o nome do banco sempre vai ter
uma enxurrada de processo, então vai dificultar muito
a sua busca, tá?
Pelo nome do devedor fica muito mais fácil.
Coloque o nome do devedor, consulta, vê se
aparece alguma coisa.
Isso se aplica a todos os Tribunais de
Justiça do país inteiro.
Vou colocar aqui TJRJ como exemplo.
Aqui no canto, busca avançada.
Por nome, você vai colocar origem, primeira instância,
todas as comarcas.
Competência, processo do devedor contra o credor é
cível.
Você pode aumentar aqui a janela e o
nome da parte.
Terceira busca, Tribunal de Justiça do Espírito Federal
e Territórios.
No Google também, consulta processual.
Hoje em dia os processos são todos eletrônicos,
só sobrou o processo físico, algo que era
bem antigo, então o processo eletrônico.
Consulta pública, primeira instância, nome da parte.
Todos os Tribunais de Justiça funcionam assim.
Não vou pesquisar aqui todos porque ficaria muito
longo.
Se for Caixa Econômica Federal, Justiça Federal.
Vamos supor que o imóvel fica em São
Paulo.
Justiça Federal de São Paulo.
No Google, seção judiciária.
Procurem nos dois, tá?
Varas e Juizados, né?
Mas vamos esperar funcionar da mesma forma, várias
federais.
Nome da parte.
Mesma coisa, Justiça Federal do Rio de Janeiro.
Consulta processual.
Sistema Apolo.
O próprio sistema já fala que dá para
procurar com o nome da parte.
Clicar aqui só para confirmar para vocês.
Nome da parte, coloque o nome do devedor.
E assim também na Justiça Federal do país
inteiro.
Então sempre faça essa busca.
É muito importante para que a gente saiba
qual é o perfil daquele devedor.
Se está enchendo saco, se está deixando o
barco tocar.
Isso vai ser um bom indício se você
vai conseguir um acordo.
Se você vai precisar ali de uma ação
de admissão na posse, tá?
Depender ali se o devedor ainda está tentando
alegar alguma coisa ou não.
Sempre faça essa pesquisa.
Passar agora então para os casos práticos.
Vamos analisar de forma completa duas oportunidades que
estavam sendo oferecidas em leilão ex-prejudicial.